say to see if it if the sound is all
well we can only pray now the Internet
can totally see you know thanks dams
today I guess man that was the other
problem that I thought were really
important for videos that are kind of
longer than 20 minutes or something oh
is that what it was
yeah a long video nice that like a UH
like a glossary or a table of contents
just in case
okay and we're back on the air after a
little detour in time we had some time
dilation over here anyways a little bit
about it what what we're about and
that's that we well let's put it in a in
a very easy way to understand if you
find something wrong with or suspect
some of the things that you're hearing
from the establishment black holes big
bang parallel universes many copies of
you each one in a different universe
every time you move a finger you end up
in a different universe zero particles
zero dimensional particles particle
duality wave packets well if you suspect
some of those things some of these
you're hearing every day you do sound
counterintuitive well maybe maybe this
is the show for you otherwise I don't
think that's what gets people a question
how does the magnetism work is it's not
that they get bad answers it's more that
they just don't get answers yeah but
people are I think a lot of people are
concerned about what they're listening
out there and one of the issues is also
that you listen to these things day
after day after day just take any
popularization magazine or journal or
whatever and what will you find you'll
find the same things said over and over
and over again they found the first
black hole the black hole has so much
mass and you know every galaxy has a
black hole in it yeah they're just over
and over and all you'll be hearing this
too until Kingdom Come let the other day
to a really long discussion with some
friends about black hole in their
existence and it just dragged on forever
yeah we're playing some game but then
awesome that came up and and and we
started like as the discussion went on
when I like it started off one it gay
and said but as it goes on you stop
playing the game we stop playing the
game less and we're more into the
discussion but it just shows how kind of
deep this feeling of like what we know
how deep how deep that runs yeah and
then there's a you question what someone
knows know yeah
so essentially you know what do we see
as irrational as counterintuitive as
what is wrong with what we're listening
to coming from the establishment it's
that they are in the business of moving
concepts you know love does not move
mountains not in not in physics maybe in
poetry but not in physics and this is
more or less what you see every day you
hear about transfer of energy moving a
mass dilating time and you know we read
about this we are educated to use these
words in high school and it turns out
that all these are concepts and the
question is whether physics is about the
physical world or about the abstract
world in other words can you move in
abstraction can you move a concept and I
think the answer a rational person would
say no you can't and if you can't then
we have a problem with what the
establishment is putting out there
because all their words or concepts
officially word we're a invisible entity
is involved as a mediator then they
introduce concept they say oh that's
energy and what is energy what is a
field what is mass and that's what you
run into trouble because these words
first of all are not defined second you
know they're used differently by
different people
depending on the context and then
they're all concepts and so you can't
say that you move the mass you
transferred energy and that's
essentially the bottom line with all
this you know that's the main big point
there and we're trying to do instead is
provide a physical interpretation or a
literal interpretation
yeah a literal interpretation what do we
mean by that we mean that you can make a
movie of the theory you can imagine yeah
in other words I can make a movie and
you can watch it and you can understand
the mechanism that doesn't mean you
believe I thought about that when I was
building the faucet because a faucet
broke and instructions of building the
faucet there's no language there it's
just pictures where we just goes where
and I was just thinking no energy this
is interesting when you see the
instructions that it's supposed to be
like for dummies but you see the
instructions and there's no language is
just just like pictures arrows and
emotions in like Aero form it's all
pictures so that anyone can understand
it it's self-evident if you follow the
instructions is that kind of thing I
just thought it was like this is a
physical recipe yeah I can imagine you
making a movie of that you know frame by
frame this is that's essentially free
did the most important frames yeah it's
it's a it's a 10 frame movie yeah each
one is just the the crucial frame that
you need to know you don't need to know
all the steps in between like moving
your arm into the thing but the main
point here again is we don't move
concepts or we object to the motion
they're not supposed to be literal yeah
physics is literal mother nature does
not work with concepts hopefully
hopefully she works out there with
physical objects and if that's the case
then there should be no reason to
explain a mechanism like gravity or
magnetism or how the atom works with a
physical object you make a movie you say
look this is what I propose is that what
you're supposed to believe it's what
you're supposed to understand I explain
you understand that's the end of physics
right there you under
Stud whether you believe or not that's
your personal business anyways we don't
have a great show today all we wanted to
let you know is that we came back from a
little recess we went we were on the
road and now we're gonna continue on the
road we're gonna go to Argentina where
we have a petite conference and it's
gonna be about these issues what we're
gonna do our best to do here is we're
gonna take some of the equipment down
south and see if we can broadcast from
Argentina
the first thing we're gonna broadcast
the conference if we can do that and I
think we can but you know you never know
until you get there but so I don't want
a promise I'm just gonna promise that I
will do my best to make sure that we can
have a transmission and and while we're
down there you've been after the
conference we might hold a couple
sessions of cultural lectures and
broadcast those as well so stay tuned
Bessy all those people who are
affiliated with patreon and you know
we're gonna try to transmit and
broadcast over here okay what else there
anything else we got to talk about I
will be here yeah okay so on tyr he's my
youngest son he's a skinhead more or
less to be a skinhead little boy against
your will hair dryer anyways we're gonna
go down there he might stay down there
if he does we might have a weird
situation where he's gonna participate
from Argentina ask questions get
involved as well it's for sure gonna be
a different show yeah
maybe 12 months yeah for a couple months
up we're gonna have a little bit of
different shows so be aware of that and
other than that nothing much except stay
tuned for the broadcasts are coming up
okay and again only if you believe that
there's something wrong and what you
hear out there
it's counterintuitive to you then this
might be the show for you the you know
the they're gonna hear a different belt
another way of thinking about is we're
kind of like the simplified version yeah
I mean it's not very simple when you get
into the details but it's the simplified
version because it's understandable just
say someone can actually follow along
yeah I'm not have to just take things on
faith and be like okay black holes we'll
just take that one you know and there's
a couple things involved with that as
well and that's that you know the
question is whether mother nature runs a
very simple universe kindergarten
universe that anybody can understand a
ten-year-old kid or whether she runs a
very complex universe that no one can
understand which is the status quo today
I think everyone thinks the second one
yeah that's more when people think of
just the vastness of the universe they
think how could how is there something
instead of nothing all those questions
it's all it all stems from are all that
we're even here yeah religious beliefs
the resistance is is a monster but
religious people and the atheists alike
are just all in all that we can eat
apples and write bikes and just live
normal lives and I think that's where
people just resort to okay then it must
be so complicated we can't understand
the mind of God kind of thing where I
mean even when we get into the details
of the universe of like the details of
the details like the MIDI nitty-gritty
of the atom or the vastness of like
specific things like the edge of the
universe even by your hypothesis it gets
pretty weird and you start have to
bending your brain not in irrational
ways but you kind of start having to
think outside of the box a lot and say
okay I mean just when you try to draw
our carbon atom with another carbon atom
all the atoms i've tried to do all the
atoms connect it's a monster yeah no no
but this I when I say simple when I say
simple is that is that we have you know
there's a famous one-liner that is used
a lot in mathematical physics and that
that and that's that first the gut
grand unified theory and then then the
universe is supposed to be simple and
symmetric and when I say it's simple and
also symmetric in fact I'm referring to
the fact that you know the model were
proposing the thing that underlies
everything is the model that consists of
two atoms connected by a rope that's
awesome Buddhist from that from that
model we're gonna try to explain gravity
the the most important phenomena or the
invisible for now gravity the behavior
of light and and magnetism and
electricity but I think and of works and
the workings of the atom so those are
the things that we're trying to focus on
and all I'm saying is that you know if
you have a system consisting of a very
simple and symmetric you know system
here two two balls essentially which is
two atoms hydrogen atoms connected by a
by a rope that's a simple and a
symmetric as it gets but I think it's
the right way of saying is that the
hypothesis is simple but the consequence
is the theories everything that comes
out of it you get so many possibilities
it's kind of like the billiard you know
the triangle you set it up okay then you
as soon as you get so many possibilities
branches out the other made me laugh was
the basic hypothesis our assumption that
all the atoms and neutrons now we have a
new new buddy in the family all the
atoms in the neutrons in the universe
are made not connected I mean they are
connected but they're essentially all
one thread and then in the in the living
room because this thing so you talking
and I told my dad so you and I are
essentially the universe talking to
itself where the thread just kind of
trying to figure out what it is it just
gets weird or when you say there's
there's no Big Bang that all the matter
in the universe was and always will be I
mean it's easy to say but then when you
really start thinking
concetto first planet there is no first
human maybe because you know if we can
beat now Sun explodes but we can happen
in a different area of nothingness but
nobody even there yes even even when you
look at the thread the single thread
hypothesis the fact that we're saying
all matter is connected but not only
connected but all matter is is made of
this single thread close loop thread
assuming you know if that that
assumption alone
is as simple as it gets I mean I think
any ten-year-old kid would understand
how does a single thread in the entire
universe that's that you're proposing as
an assumption right keep in mind that's
an assumption the assumption is simple
but everything that you all the
conclusions do you draw from a simple
assumption get really weird
yeah and MSC oh that's the fun part
that's the fun part but and you know the
second part of that one is the fact that
all these you know mathematical physics
they use concepts as up physical objects
that's one problem but then there's the
issue of you know undefined language
that is used you know a lot of these
words are not defined if you look up
words such as energy mass time the end
result will be always the same oh we
don't know what it is we we can't define
them very well
but we'll use it anyways and that's
another serious problem and and it shows
again that these words are concepts that
people are trying to define and we're
talking about something completely
different we're saying look you know
we're saying this is a ball this is cat
this is a tree this is a house a rock
you know we're talking about objects and
we don't define an object we point to
them yeah but I named them so the
definition are defined words part the
best analogy we came up with after so
many discussions even in front of the
camera in fact I think we came up with
it from the camera was the talking to a
program or a robot analogy yeah because
with undefined terms essentially what
you're doing is you're trying to
you're not putting a fine point on
exactly what you're saying so that it
can be followed logically but like logic
with perfect logic it's yeah it's with
an undefined word you're kind of winky
winky like okay you know what I mean
like you're trying to find some common
ground but it's not this perfect
language that can be kind of copy pasted
essentially language that the program
could understand could follow yeah and
and it really comes down to logic if you
use a word in one way here and then
another way here just beautiful because
you didn't define it specifically
because if you don't define a word
precisely then you can use it very
broadly and it kind of turns more into
poetry instead of science you're not
speaking literally and you can get away
with murder
yeah and and that's an objective way of
checking your language you know don't
don't try to convince me just put it in
the computer see see if you can convince
the computer I think I just mix it back
out and says look yeah I don't I think
you're using it inconsistently or I
can't follow your instruction because I
don't understand what that word means
well there you have an objective you
know way of telling whether your
definition is rational I think a future
scientist will understand the analogy
now or if you use something you can't
you
once you define something the computer
will always use it in a specific way
yeah and there's no such thing as a
vague definition in programming all
right I need a robot because the cook
the robot doesn't have its own pool of
knowledge to interpret what you say yeah
you have to give them exactly your
interpretations and that's kind of how
it should be in physics that way the
logic can be followed flawlessly yeah
whether he listens to it whether he
listens to it she listens to it if you
define your terms in such a way that it
cannot be misunderstood then you're
doing science because if you're not then
you're giving poetry yeah
yeah and so that's it you know we want
to make sure that people who tuned in
are people first that are a little
uncomfortable what they hear out there
it could be people out there simply want
to listen you know to hear another side
of the story you know
there's at least two bells in every
argument and you want to hear both bells
or just to know what scientists are
saying because I mean even if I'm into
black holes I don't like my friends
didn't know what a black hole is like if
I asked him directly okay what is it
provide call don't know that's the
scientist yeah okay yeah if you believe
in black holes and you just want to know
what is a black hole without without
weird analogies or I guess the best way
of saying is what what is Bill's take on
what the establishment thinks black
holes are yeah that's another thing that
that we do we we do analyze a lot of
what they do out there
partly so that you can get your own
weapons if you're unsatisfied with what
you hear out there then you're gonna
hear a good analysis of what what we
think is wrong with what they're doing
out there today the mathematicians and
and so one of the issues is to provide
you with arguments or that you at least
hear arguments that you won't hear every
day you know from from the establishment
itself you'll never see any dissent
between people from the universities
people who have big names or at least
they won't put such a fine point on
their own flaws yeah yeah up with a
theory yeah if they come up with a
theory they're gonna obviously they're
gonna have areas where they're still
researching but they won't put a fine
point on that they'll just say Oh
gravitational waves have been discovered
but they don't tell you all the problems
or how it happened or all the details
yeah and here we kind of harp on the
details a little too much of yes but no
no we try to yeah we do harp on the
details because sometimes people want to
know a little more a little more a
little more they say well hold I didn't
understand this little thing and that
takes you to another can another thing
and another thing because the Devils in
Devils yeah sometimes you got to go on
that tangent for a little while and
cover all those you know make sure with
your vadhana you you cut all the you
know the jungle there and then come back
and hopefully you continue on your
journey
when you're talking physics it's all
about the details the other day in that
same day when you're talking about black
holes somehow we went off into a tangent
of the difference between speed and
acceleration or if you're on a train and
you throw a ball up but it's
accelerating does it fall back in your
hand it's a simple question that anyone
can kind of even test I mean geez and
and it was and we just kept going around
in circles and circles and circles it
was just all with more analogies with
more analogies and more more complicated
now somehow we ended up from for example
train we went it up on an airplane
that's accelerating or weight the earth
is accelerating or decelerating around
the Sun okay let me explain it with the
earth and it just gives way more
complicatedly gravity and now Z's
getting mom with off but yeah we do we
would like to go into those details
because you know people are time people
sometimes want to know very simple
examples and and examples maybe they
never thought about like you know very
simple you throw the ball up in the air
and while you're driving in a car will
it fall back in your hand is there a
motion of the ball forward because the
car moves forward that sort of thing
does a fly that is flying in an airplane
does he get dragged also with the
airplane or does it you know does it
weigh down or does it hit the bathroom
wall I mean everybody just simple kind
of bro science the questions yes okay
there's a there's a fly flying in a
plane that's also flying does the fly
way down on the plane questions like
that they're just like oh it's good to
know like it's not doesn't and doesn't
answer any big questions they've only go
into the universe or like atoms but it's
just fun fact kind of things no but yeah
also gives you an idea what physics is
above but the real physics is about
because you know that these are
questions of physics you know that does
if you throw two stones one way is twice
as much as the other we would fall twice
as fast you know most people would say
you know intuitively yeah the heavier
stone falls faster it turns out they
fall at the same time and you get
situations like that that a lot of
people say home and that's
counterintuitive I didn't know that and
simple things like that sometimes you
need to have you need to analyze to some
agree and explain why some such thing
has happened what is the point of
knowing these things no just this for
fun but it's it wasn't you in the in the
sense that you know it sometimes it
shocks you intuition but if any times it
does you know I think it's also about
kind of knowing now give fixes your
logic fixes your way of thinking because
if you're trying to solve I don't know
like some detective crime and you have
some problem with your analysis or way
of breaking something down then you end
up with wrong conclusions down the line
like it might have unseen effects
somewhere down the line like a crass one
would be if you didn't know the the
gravity you know pulls on you at a
certain speed or if you did if you
didn't know certain things you could
jump out of the balcony and kill
yourself not knowing it has a craftsman
that we all kind of know it's yes an
ambush but smaller things also kinda add
up if you have enough small physical
misconceptions they add up to
they might add up to something down the
line yeah useful like tool wise speaking
anyways we're going to Argentina Buenos
Aires this week and we're gonna be
broadcasting from over there if we can
we're gonna do our best to try to
broadcast and especially we're gonna
broadcast you know the presentations so
don't go too far away if you're
interested you might hear something that
is interesting okay and so we'll see you
then
we'll see you sometime this week
probably at the end of the week right
maybe around Saturday there abouts we're
probably going to have our first
transmission so tune in I'm gonna be
putting a notice like I did today in the
rational scientific method group in
Facebook and it's gonna be again like
this on you too so we're gonna do our
best
broadcast you know to anyone who's
interested okay make it global so we'll
see you then we'll see you next week
hopefully on Saturday okay we'll see you
then bye bye